we were calling it like a DJ it's you're
emotional at work DJ's so you know when
you need everything really ramped up and
going strong like a DJ knows how to do
but then when it's time to calm the
crowd down maybe our software can learn
okay Mary needs to take a break Mary
needs to slow down Mary needs to go get
a glass of water you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it I'm your host Gretchen using
[Applause]
[Music]
emotions are fundamental to human
interaction but in a world where humans
are increasingly interacting with AI
systems dr. Mary sure Winsky principal
researcher and research manager of the
visualization and interaction for
business and entertainment group at
Microsoft Research believes emotions may
be fundamental to our interactions with
machines as well and through her team's
work in affective computing the quest to
bring artificial emotional intelligence
or AEI
to our computers may be closer than we
think today dr. chair Winsky tells us
how a cognitive psychologist found her
way into the research division of the
world's largest software company
suggests that rather than trying to be
productive 24/7 we should aim for
emotional homeostasis instead and tells
us how if we do it right our machines
could become a sort of emotional at work
DJ sensing and responding to our
emotional states and helping us to
become happier and more productive at
the same time that and much more on this
episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
marry chewinski welcome to the podcast
today it's great to have you with us
thank you it's an honor to be here so
you work under the larger umbrella of
human-computer interaction at Microsoft
Research but more specifically you're
the principal researcher and the
research manager of the vibe group right
tell us what vibe stands for and what
gets people in your group up in the
morning vibe stands for visualization
and interaction for business and
entertainment most the people in the
group are very deeply into various
aspects of information visualization so
helping people work with big data better
or building tools for programmers that
programmers can deal with all the vast
amounts of data we have coming in these
days or in the area of effective
computing which is where I'm squarely
putting my research these days Microsoft
Research has a number of social science
researchers now yes but you actually
were the first social science researcher
how did you end up here did they come
looking for you who decided they needed
a PhD in cognitive psychology to help
with computer science research that's a
great question I took the initiative to
meet with Dan Lang who is managing all
of research at that time and talked to
him about social science and the
benefits of having social scientists on
their research teams but it was actually
Eric Horvitz and George Robertson that
actually sought me out as a psychologist
to partner with them in their research
around attention and rendering on the
screen and redesigning windows in 3d and
so the two of them really kind of helped
usher me over to research I was actually
in product at the time so I was in
Microsoft just wasn't in the research
group so it was a great time to come out
into the field as a cognitive
psychologist because back then we had
one computer screen and it was all about
users being able to look at the screen
and make sense of it well that's what
cognitive psychologists study perception
and cognition around information
learning memory making decisions
attending to various aspects of the
displays so it was perfect timing for me
to put what I did my PhD in to work for
Microsoft you know I would have not even
gone there
in terms of that thinking just given
where we are today with the attention
economy they're calling it yes and
there's so many more demands on our
attention so tell me how it's evolved
since when you started Tanana yeah well
I mean back then the experiments we
would do for instance with the
astronauts at Johnson Space Center I
would be looking at their layouts of
their displays and they'd be running
nine experiments at a time and they had
to monitor them all the time in addition
to the various Space Station systems
like thermonuclear control just kind of
important and so we looked at
character-based user interfaces and how
people contract that kind of information
that all changed when graphical user
interfaces came along and then it was
more about how you grouped things and
how you arranged them on the screen and
it's still about that today that hasn't
gone away but now you know everything's
more social and now we have multiple
devices and multiple displays we have to
look at so it's just fanned our
attention out even more broadly and
harder to control obvious yeah so makes
your job a little harder to us yes but
that's exciting yeah it's really fun
your research focuses on a couple of big
ideas in motion tracking information
worker task management and healthcare
and wellness for individuals and groups
and we'll get to each of those in turn
okay but for starters let's talk a
little bit about this big idea of
effective computing and the quest for
artificial emotional intelligence or AEI
what is it and why is it important well
I don't think we'll actually have quite
natural user interfaces and so we can
actually talk to our systems the way you
and I naturally talk to each other and
so a large part of that is these really
natural almost automatic social signals
that we cue off of each other so the way
you're nodding your head gently in
agreement with me is the way that I know
that you're mimicking me basically in my
thoughts so we believe that systems will
need to have that kind of emotional
intelligence EQ yeah in order for them
to be natural enough for us to really
engage with them and want to keep
engaging with them so there's not that
freaky uncanny valley where it just
doesn't feel natural it doesn't feel
right so we've been pursuing this
emotion
in order to track your emotion as a user
so that the system can respond more like
a human would emotionally appropriately
so do you think we'll ever get real
artificial emotional intelligence with a
machine well that's TBD I would rather
be on the edge exploring those things as
they happen as a scientist and trying to
make the most of it part of your
research involves designing what you
call delightful systems but it isn't
always easy to tell whether they're
really delightful or not how are you
tackling this Mary I like to say how can
we say that we're designing systems that
delight our users if we don't actually
know so that is why we are using cameras
and microphones to look at our users
faces to see what their facial gestures
are are they smiling are they squinting
their eyes are they frowning but also
listen to their voices hear how they're
saying things about working with our
systems and if we can build these kinds
of emotions sensing platforms into all
of our products then we'll know from the
get-go if we're actually designing
systems and tools that users are
delighted by or are they frustrated and
then we should fix those areas that seem
to bring on the frustration so I think
if you build these tools in to the
platform of all of our systems that we
build in the future we'll know better if
we're making you know systems and
software that people love you were part
of a recorded presentation called
and how does that make you feel but I
loved the name of you know it's like the
psychiatrist yes exactly and it's
several points you got frustrated with
the fact that your video wouldn't play
and about the third time you actually
flashed a big smile and go
that's just great and I remember
thinking how would I as a machine know
that you weren't really happy and
delighted with me that's a great
question that's a great question because
we never think now I'm channeling Daniel
Macduff on my team and we never believed
that a one to ten second slice of a
users face is going to give us anything
worthwhile what we believe in is that
you have to watch and listen to this
user for a long time
longitudinally so that we really
understand the range of a person's
emotions people are all over the place
with
how labile their emotional state is I'm
pretty up and down I have a broad range
um but some people aren't some people
are much you know flatter or just more
controlled with their emotions and so
you really do have to study an
individual for a long time before you
know but then also the Machine needs
context about what you're doing so if
the machine had been watching and seeing
I couldn't play my video the machine
would learn that that smile is probably
a smile of complete frustration or Ermis
yarra grimace I grimacing smile it could
have been but yeah so the Machine needs
the context and the longitudinal data
about you yourself as a person before it
can have really good sure Dennis and
that's making the right emotional
classification so that's an interesting
thread to drill in on because you want
to build up a system that will work for
many people not just one person and if
my emotional ups and downs are different
from hers then how are you gonna bring
the research together and make a machine
that can tell the difference if you need
to track me for a long time in him for a
life you know yeah I'm Sam million yeah
well because you can do this now is
simple webcam and mic on any laptop or
PC it's pretty easy and the user doesn't
have to do anything to do this kind of
tracking longitudinally and we're doing
it right now here in building 99 many of
us are getting our emotions classified
while we're using everyday software
systems and doing our regular work so
now we have thousands and thousands of
hours of these emotions tracked and we
can bring them back to bear not only
with generalized models but also
personalized models that could be more
relevant just to me so we can do both
scales quite well okay so you could even
employ machine learning AI to actually
customize in a particular product for a
particular person yes yes that's the
angle that would be cool mm-hmm
[Music]
you frame some of your research in the
category of productivity tools mm-hmm
tell us about the technology you're
working on to help mitigate negative
interruptions multitasking or I think
you really would call it task switching
cuz right there's no such thing at least
that's what I tell my daughter they're
not multitasking and some of the general
lack of focus that we experience at work
and if we're honest in life yes you know
I do a lot of work with Sean Z Iqbal and
Gloria mark and Gloria has really opened
my eyes to the fact that everybody has a
really different personality some people
it turns out are quite adept at managing
their workflow so they stay pretty
concentrated and focused for longer
periods of time than other people and
they take breaks when they know that
they need to when they need to refresh
because no one can stay focused 24/7
that's a myth so we like to refer to
something called emotional homeostasis
which is you stay focused you work hard
maybe you are even a little stressed and
then you do something to balance that
out right so maybe you use social media
if you're one of those people but other
people have a harder time staying
focused for longer periods of time and
actually every time they hear a ping or
every time they get an email
notification they go to it
you know the little numbers on the icons
are the worst thing for these kinds of
people because they see they have
something new and have to go check it so
but those kinds of people we can
actually use machine learning and this
personalized kind of software we've been
talking about to see when you need to be
in the flow to see when you actually do
your best work and to kind of help you
stay there so perhaps that's the time
when you're really starting to get into
your work perhaps that's the time we
turn off notifications or hold less high
priority notifications away from you
turn off that inbox you know dinger and
let you focus we might even turn off
social media if we go so far the user
gives us permission to do that we'll do
whatever the user wants us to do to keep
them in the zone and then you know when
you tend to kind of come out of that
flow maybe it's right before lunch let
it all flow back that will be just fine
and the Machine
can see that you're moving out of the
zone and it's going to turn back on
automatically this is current research
we're doing right now this is our
hypothesis that we'll be able to see
when you prefer to have your hard core
work moments and when you are okay with
letting notifications through impossible
work breaks through or we can see if
you're one of those people that stays
really focused maybe we can see you've
been focused a little too long for
yourself maybe you are getting a little
stressed out and a little walk would be
quite welcome at that point but it's all
work that's in progress with so we still
don't know how these we kind of like we
were calling it like a DJ it's your
emotional at work DJ's so you know when
you need everything really ramped up and
going strong like a DJ knows how to do
but then when it's time to calm the
crowd down maybe our software can learn
okay Mary needs to take a break Mary
needs to slow down Mary needs to go get
a glass of water bio break something you
know so we'll see how much users will be
welcoming such software and we'll design
it until they do welcome it will iterate
it and do it better if we're using these
tools to get in the zone and stay there
should we call it artificial
productivity no it's real project it's
artificially assisted artificially
assisted product yeah yeah well so let
me ask you this as a psychologist what
happened to good old-fashioned self
discipline have we just lost that in
this digital world I will tell you in a
study we ran two summers ago a couple of
our participants we turned off all their
social media all their notifications
they weren't allowed to use their phone
for eight hours a day and a couple of
our participants did make note of the
fact that they had lost sight of how
often they were going to social media
and checking their phones and they were
shocked by how much more time they had
so in some sense the sad truth is yes we
have trained ourselves to do this task
switching on an almost constant basis
and on a great note software can help so
you know maybe we can train it back
let's get a little meta on that topic
and this whole concept of digital
assistants and effective agents and kind
of on the same note we really reached
the point where we need technology to
save us from our technology I just did a
press interview yesterday where
did actually make the claim that we need
technology to help us from our
technologies so I can stand by that I've
said that but as I said all of our tasks
switching bad behavior was trained it
was trained by the tools and features
that we asked software companies to
build for us or tech companies in
general so we can use the technology to
retrain ourselves to focus I believe we
can I know we can the research shows we
can and will make better decisions we'll
do better at our jobs and we'll be more
productive so yes if we have to start
using technology as training wheels to
get rid of all the bad technology that's
that's you know bifurcating and and and
dividing our attention I don't think
that's a bad thing I think it's a good
thing we've come around full circle from
a psychological point of view aren't we
at the risk of outsourcing some basic
human skill sets that are emotional that
are necessary for emotional growth and
health great so I wouldn't say that we
fund that far but it is nice that we can
use the machine intelligence to kind of
protect us again and get us back into
focus I think that's going to be great
in terms of the emotional side of things
I really do think that the advent of
robots taking care of children and the
elderly
it's almost upon us and that is an
outsourcing in my personal opinion
possibly a necessary one but it's still
an outsourcing and so that's why I'm
really really vehement ly opposed to not
studying what the effects of children
using robots and personal assistance is
on their own communication growth and
behavior but also I'm really adamant
that machines need to have EQ not
because I don't want you to know that
you're working with a machine or a robot
but because I want that conversation to
have an emotional balance and to be
emotionally mature so that kids don't
grow up with this imbalance with lack of
EQ lack of real intelligence right so I
think it goes both ways and that's why
it want to study both of those aspects
of it because it could be worrisome
right absolutely mm-hmm so on that
thread effective computing as I'm
looking at it seems to have two sides to
it one is designing machines that can
interpret human emotional states and
adapt to them and the other is designing
machines that can help humans interpret
their own emotional states first am i
right and second if so why is this
two-sided approach necessary and
happening most people aren't very aware
of their emotional state and so what we
find when we first start doing our
experiments that actually takes people a
day or two to actually start
understanding how they actually feel I'm
usually in the positive quadrant of how
we do these self ratings and it took me
even a little while to realize I'm not
always you know happy and high energy
right sometimes I am kind of low energy
sometimes I am sad so after you track
yourself for a while and you are honest
with yourself then you start to realize
how the states move around and so in any
experiment we always know that at the
very beginning users might not be super
good at it but they'll get better at it
over time and I think that it is very
useful because we forget our emotional
states very very quickly a quick little
survey we did showed people forget how
they were feeling about a day and if
it's a really big event that happened in
your life you're probably gonna remember
how you felt it's those little patterns
of micro badness and micro goodness we
don't actually pay that much attention
to yeah and it could really help us make
better decisions like for instance
people were telling us after like a week
of tracking themselves and whatnot that
they wouldn't remember these things a
year from now so having a system that
tracked it would be quite useful now it
has to track it accurately
so yeah there should be a way that you
can correct the system when it's wrong
but I think it's kind of nice to go back
and look at how I was feeling and
actually I'm still always surprised I am
happier most of the time right and
frustrated very little over time but
there are moments you would forget
otherwise so it's useful to you might be
useful if you were taking care of a
loved one to be able to see those tracks
right now most people go to a therapists
office or doctor's office they fill out
a paper form for how they've been
feeling the last four weeks well people
don't remember how they were feeling the
last four weeks so these tools can be
very useful they could be shared with
loved ones and caregivers yeah so let me
ask a question about that if I'm going
to be monitored in all these situations
what's watching me what's recording what
I want to know is I'm in front of my
computer right now okay
and it's a laptop uh-huh and I might be
working at a desktop at my desk but out
in the wild I don't have these though
right no you would have to have some
device that has a camera and/or a mic
but you can have either one
okay that's constantly listening to you
in those particular contexts that you
might want it to right now it's very
easy when people are just at their desk
or in a meeting so actually we're
tackling meetings next which will be
fascinating oh wow yeah but yeah you
would have to have some kind of
recording device on you if you wanted to
get it 24/7 all day long well let's talk
about that for a second and we'll swing
back to some other topics increasingly
the mechanisms that are collecting data
include video audio maybe wearables
ingestible x' implantables Lunchables I
don't know how do we reconcile the
desire to have this knowledge this
quantified self this self-awareness with
our desire for privacy and our fear of
Big Brother great no that's why we do
everything we can to keep your signal
private to you
there's no identifiable information that
goes into the cloud at all we as
researchers can't go in and look at your
data if you're running our system we
can't and so is it encrypted I mean how
would I be confident you are completely
D identifiable we can't find you unless
you give us a code back you know your ID
and tell us you want your data which of
course we can give you if you want it
that's the only way we know who you are
well I just interviewed Kristin Lauder
who works in crypto right and it's like
all of the different teams that come
together to make these tools both
fantastic and trustworthy at the same
time is super important and we will
surely use her stuff we work with Ronnie
on her team so he talks to me about what
they're doing all the time that's good
it'll be a good thing to have yeah in
fact you used a funny phrase to frame
the human-computer interaction groups
relationship to other groups at
Microsoft tell us what it is a why you
say it
yeah human-computer interaction people
often play the glue between various
technology teams because we're usually
the user-facing part of the experiment
and we can see when you know there's a
tick
that's very right to present to a user
but it needs something like we were just
talking about it needs encrypted privacy
so we'll bring the two teams that need
to talk to each other together because
we go out and put our user interfaces on
all of their technologies so we kind of
know what they're doing so that's why I
say that
sure so tell me what's going on in the
research stage and then even in the
product stage on things that can help me
track my emotions or my state of being
at work what we do know is that users
really could use help from our
technology to turn off notifications to
possibly turn off non-work-related
websites like social media and help the
user focus and maybe the user just wants
to say something like I just want to
turn all that off for a half hour then
I'll be fine and the system should help
them do that eventually the goal would
be to do that automatically for the user
so user doesn't have to remember to do
something manually or on their own hmm
that's an interesting thing I don't know
if it's better if I develop the skill to
remember to turn it off right or to have
somebody do it for me we have to do
Studies on all of this right right
[Music]
one of the biggest problems I have and I
know I'm not alone is wrangling and
making sense of my data how are you
helping me
ah well I know you did a podcast of
Steven Drucker very cool that does
wonderful work and information
visualization that we have many
researchers that do work in information
visualization at Microsoft Research and
they're all fabulous they all take
different aspects of how you look at
your data some of them like to work with
networked data some of them like to work
with time based data so there are many
many tools in the info vis community
info vis stands for information
visualization thank you're welcome that
can be thrown at these kinds of big data
problems yeah another thing that
Danielle Fisher has done in our group
which I thought was really nice is he
starts to show you your data as it's
coming in but if there's so much data
that you can't all be rendered at once
it just gives you a feel for what the
data is gonna look like and you decide
when you think you have enough to make a
decision so they're all working with
these kinds of interactive visualization
tools to help you see patterns in your
data that you might not have been able
to see you know in an Excel spreadsheet
using standard bar graphs or line graphs
so you said some of this is still in the
research stage but some of its already
incorporated into bi and Excel and
things like that
yes power bi has been a great vehicle
for taking visualization work and
exposing it to end-users and I think
it's been very helpful it's very hard to
come up with novel visualizations so it
takes a lot of creativity a lot of work
to hook up something that people can use
pretty quickly because they're usually
pretty sophisticated versus the standard
bar chart or pie charts so it does take
users a little while to learn how to use
them but then when they do they're very
powerful and useful yeah yeah let's look
to the future for a second I'm your
group is publishing prolifically you're
going to kai in a bit with a lot of
papers what excites you most about what
the field is doing right now and what
might be exciting to the next generation
of human-computer interaction scholars
right well I think the whole movement
towards the gig economy
is really new and exciting and it
studied pretty hard at KY it's
represented pretty well at KY so I tend
to go into two tracks when I met KY
because they're like 14 parallel tracks
so you have to pick and I tend to go
into mental health and health and then I
try to go to the gig economy tracks
because that world is moving so fast so
the advent of microtasks
or merging you know even just think of
writing a word document now we have
researchers in the building who are
working on just taking little parts of
writing that document and making it a
task for somebody to do out there write
a meet even imagine a podcast on this
okay good and Sean Z Iqbal is doing it
as well as some others but that economy
whether you're talking about taxi
drivers to airplane designers that
economy is going gig and so it's just
fascinating to listen to hear the
research they're doing and the trends
that are happening and how those gig
workers actually work with each other to
make sure each other's succeed and they
make a good wage so to me I always
follow those two tracks and I think the
young guns will need to do a lot of work
on the gig economy it's really exciting
but also a health and mental health I
mean really moving fast and using
machine learning to look at you know
precision psychology for instance is a
huge topic so I'm hoping the young
people look at those two areas but there
are many more very hot areas those are
just my two favorite we talked about
what gets you up in the morning is there
anything particularly that keeps you up
at night Mary yes I do get worried about
our systems that will eventually have
good EQ but they don't yet and how
working with the systems today when
they're not truly intelligent they don't
filter by age gender location etc in
terms of what they say pretty much these
days I worry that it changes people's
communication patterns because they're
going to pattern off the system so I
really get worried in particular about
young people the elderly I imagine their
morals are already built in and they've
learned their communication style pretty
well by now but I really worry about the
young generation and the generation that
maybe as we said maybe they're going to
be working more with a robot than they
are with you know a teaching assistant
in the future so I want to make sure
that that modeling
is what we as a society see is
appropriate moral and positive so I
really want to focus on generational
issues like that and also what is the
appropriate EQ for a machine right do
you want to know that it's not human I
think most of us want to know that it's
not human and so how do you do that and
yet still make the conversation feel
natural and make the conversation feel
appropriate that question is so profound
because what much of the work happening
here is about is making computers more
human-like and yet when you ask that
question do you want to know I'm nodding
my head really hard yes I want to know
it's not I don't want to be fooled by
the Turing test great great so we have
to again as a society come up with a
plan basically hmm you doing that
thinking about it hard if you weren't a
researcher what would you be I really
wanted to go back and get my PhD in bio
psychology at one point I you know I
can't not be a researcher it's just
gonna say you answered that by saying I
see a different kinda researcher tennis
player I'd do it but I don't have the
talent so it's not gonna happen last
question what advice would you give to
your 25 year old self hmm this is for
the researchers out there who would be
looking at what do i do where do I put
my time talent treasure yeah what I tend
to tell young people that I mentor
they're still in graduate school for
instance because that's about 25 I tell
them not to think that life is just a
straight line
right it's never a straight line you
don't get your PhD and go from point A
to point B to Point C to point D
sometimes if you stay in academia that
can happen but even then I don't think
your career is gonna go in a straight
line too much happens and in my
particular case technology changes way
too fast
so you always have to be open to
something I thought for sure I was gonna
go into academia I couldn't because of a
two-body problem I ended up in industry
oh my god was that the best thing for me
ever that was just perfect and then I
jumped around right I went to Johnson
Space Center I went to
communications research I kept my foot
in academia because I thought you know
someday I might want to teach again got
this wonderful job at compact which led
me to Microsoft which led me to
Microsoft Research you know you just got
to stay open and you'll know when it's
time to leave things won't feel right
and then that great opportunity might be
out there and just be open to it
Mary sure Winsky thanks for joining us
today and sharing so much about what
you're doing and we can't wait to see
what's gonna happen thank you it's my
pleasure to learn more about dr. Mary
karinski
and how to have a better relationship
with your computer visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]